and the only player in the nba who
spends his whole check
on waxing the hair off his shoulders i'm
talking about
andre drummond
yeah a lot of people here that i love
tonight we got a little pump
we got little zan uh these are also the
reasons that your 12 year old cousin
wants a face tattoo stop writing on your
goddamn face
stop writing on your face it's stupid
you're not going to get a job
if this [ __ ] don't work out stop it
george ladies and gentlemen
[Music]
[Applause]
come on paul
get off the stage paul your moment is
over get
i'm down repeat that rihanna was kicked
off of instagram
for excessive nudity what the [ __ ]
listen rihanna being banned from
instagram
is like banning a waffle house from from
basically
having videos on world star hip-hop it
would be a stupid sight
tell you something else she's so sexy
that i would honestly pay a million
dollars to see her naked
here's the thing i've already seen it
and i'm willing to pay again
i would i would still pay for it how
many men are mad that she didn't come
naked
2014 2015 second team all nba
and he's also a platinum member of
beyonce's beehive
which means that he gets autographed
photos and the pups wanted to meet three
people
i'm talking about little marcus aldridge
see you never know what's going to
happen at the vmas
i mean beasts pop off bad language
people run to the bathroom and send out
crazy tweets
it's basically like your typical day at
the white house and you face trump suck
it
at this moment i want you to look to
your left and look to your right
if you see somebody stooping down or
sweating it's because they got warrants
and guess what
you're going to jail tonight and i got a
couple people that i want to get locked
up
okay he's also a two-time kia all-star
and the mvp was one of the nba's best
dressed for his rendition of princess
but she jeans
let's hear it for russell westbrook
there you go russell
the genes are a blast buddy
[Music]
[Applause]
what what is this what are you talking
about i'm a busy man
okay look i got to be at four places at
once so this one right here this one
this one over here i'm filming scenes
from a new movie this is wedding ringer
too that's what i'm doing on this one
right here dude
why do we know one hasn't even come out
yet floyd mayweather congratulations on
the fight buddy but you're going to jail
for those
damn cowboy boots you're going to jail i
want to lock you up tonight that was a
bad fashion choice
uh keychains you wore a suit tonight
that's not you
jail
get out the way get out
get out the way go ahead man
[Applause]
the earth is not flat it's not flat
hey this one this one over here well
this is my new reality show it's called
straight from the heart matter of fact
wait
say hi but say hi from the heart say hi
i don't want to be on your reality show
you know i'm definitely able to do what
i do because of the help that i've had
on camera so
this one goes to all the cold stars that
i've had except the rock
because he hasn't helped me he hasn't
helped me
at all you've actually lessened my
talent it's it's went down
since you've been in my life the world
needs more dreamers
and it also needs more quiznos employees
why does it take so long in quiznos
it's just a sandwich 45 minutes is
ridiculous
stevie i see you you going to jail i
don't know why but you just need to be
locked the [ __ ] up man it's got to stop
damn it stevie they got to get you out
of here man no
okay okay that's it okay i was looking
hard look ross i go get you yes i am
velvet sweatsuit nachos
you know what will nobody else here
knows who you are and i'm gonna make
sure that they [ __ ] know tonight
will packer is the fifth black guy in
the room
and i just we i don't know why they put
us all in the same row which is [ __ ]
up they couldn't spread us out
i don't know if that's a cinema kind
thing or if that's something else
but i'm gonna get to the bottom of that
i don't know who's gonna distribute that
[Music]
that's a distributor joke i am
killing yeah amy in your face i'm
[ __ ] this crowd up
uh what's the third one which one the
third one yeah oh this is my favorite
one this right now i'm a guest
on the view right now whoopee would you
say whoopee
no don't go there you better not go
there whoopi she went there
where did she go i need to know where
did whoopi go guys
all right seriously and i don't look as
cool as i thought i would behind this
podium because you can't see my suit
this is stupid
this is really you know this is a waste
of a suit right now i was like
they're gonna [ __ ] love it but you
can't see nothing i look like a guy with
a [ __ ] head i don't know i just don't
like it
i don't have a college degree but i do
have a yacht
yeah yes we're even education who's the
who's the dummy now i only paid 30
million for it
on credit i don't even have the money
i hate your [ __ ] face
it makes me say
[Applause]
[Applause]
this [ __ ] first
with the camouflage petite jacket on it
[Music]
bye